former Reform Party leader Preston
Manning will chair a panel to review
Alberta's response to covet 19. Manning
was working on the covid-19 file last
year too he wrote a fictional account of
a commission that examined the federal
government response to the pandemic in
it he imagines the conclusions that
would result from such an investigation
he writes about how damaging the covid
restrictions were and speculates about
how public servants and politicians who
put the measures in place might be held
criminally or financially responsible
for the consequences it's also fairly
clear that that Manning has quite a bit
of sympathy with
um some of the Grievances uh that were
articulated by members of the freedom
Convoy political scientist Lisa young
says if Daniel Smith's purpose is to
hear messages that are consistent with
her own then Manning is the safe choice
but she says this doesn't have the
budget or chair for a thorough
independent review if this is primarily
a political exercise then we're left
without that public policy expert
exercise that I think many jurisdictions
are likely to go through over the next
few years a panel website asks experts
and the public to give input on what
changes should be made to Alberta laws
to better handle future Public Health
emergencies the panel has a budget of
two million dollars Manning will pocket
around 12 percent of that there are many
many better ways we could be spending a
quarter of a million dollars than paying
Preston Manning to rewrite his
apocalyptic populist fan fiction a final
report is expected in November Harold
and Curry de Castillo Global News